this program is brought to you by Emory
University our goal is to create a new
breed of super-soldier
he brought a 90 pound asthmatic on to my
army base I let it slide I am looking
for qualities their arms the physical
whatever happens say who you are not
just a soldier but a good man
you actually did it
who the hell are the first of many I'd
read the Nazi deep science division led
by Johann Schmidt
what made to you so special nothing I'm
just a kid from Brooklyn in some ways
Captain America is the arc typo Marvel
comic because think about it you have
the scrawny kid who wants desperately to
do good you have technology coming to
his rescue because remember spider-man
becomes spider-man because of technology
and a radiated spider or a genetically
modified spider the Fantastic Four
become the Fantastic Four because they
get blasted up into space
Iron Man becomes Iron Man because of
Technology over and over again you see
this theme you have good and evil in its
purest sort of American sense you have a
kid who's desperately wanting to
contribute but doesn't have the stuff
and then you have him modified in some
way to become this incredible fighting
machine but one of the real ironies of
course of Captain America is isn't that
a kind of fulfillment of the Nazi
eugenic ideal after all what the Nazis
wanted to create was the perfect Aryan
and look at Captain America Captain
America is a technologically created
perfect Aryan and so there's almost an
irony in the way in which Marvel Comics
created this anti-nazi figure by using
genetics to perfect the human form which
is exactly what the Nazis were trying to
do but of course the difference there is
that America does it in a way that
doesn't involve genocide or denigrating
any other group it's taking this poor in
fact quite the opposite they take a
specimen that in Nazi ideology would be
dispensable and they enhance that
specimen they they say all of us have
within us the ability to be great
this guy just needs a little help which
is exactly the opposite ideology of the
Nazi ideology
and yet the whole genetic idea the mean
there it just it's it creates all kinds
of interesting and philosophically and
ideologically complex relationships here
genetics is a savior just like to the
Nazis they thought genetics would be a
savior the difference is in how we think
about enhancing those in the United
States who come here with disadvantages
the ideology here was you give those
people a hand you try to help them
realize the American dream and that was
a very powerful counter mean to the
Nazis which as you destroy those people
Captain America thus becomes a really
does become a symbol of what the United
States meant and was trying to achieve
or the way in which it thought about
itself and I'm not really sure that that
was explicit in in the comic book that
idea but I think because eugenic ideas
with so much of what that period was
about World War two was about that
different model of how genetic science
can be used became a very powerful
symbol of the difference between the the
German and the American views of
Technology
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University